I decided to post a meme to troll the
ladies a little bit of the guy that says
I got another woman pregnant if you want
to leave go ahead and the girl says no I
won't leave you I will help you raise
the child and on top it says like a real
woman supposed to people were mad so are
you faith that a woman should Radha by
even when she disrespected like this no
I'm not mad
yes you good some good comments in here
are you serious and I was like you're
not a real woman if you disagree
you're a fake woman with fire-crotch you
know what made me realize is this a lot
of people are not only very susceptible
but when we talk about like the outrage
machine these are the people who are
most susceptible to that outrage the
fact that you could post to me on an
account like ours where that's the
context us posting a mean like that is
very out of place say that again us
posting a meme like that again
what do you mean you posting at me don't
be like cuz you know if I became to be
like we post this you'd be like yeah
you'll be like never I wouldn't do that
so I just roll my eyes I keep it going I
was like all right mo I'd be like
get off the keyboard that was a meet my
eyes II would you take care of a woman
this child and she see it on you
a woman's child yeah her debatable it's
not a woman style is it machi yeah if it
is not you nothing care of her kid I'm
thinking care of machi but the good news
for ladies though is like that can't
happen to them by accident they have to
consent to a man could be in a whole
relationship with a woman thing the
child's his yeah I'd not find out until
they're like 18 19 that it's not you
know I'm saying or even their whole
lives that would probably mess with me
if I was dating a girl and we have a kid
and the kid turns 12 and I find out the
kids not mind that she cheated mmm I
couldn't stay with her I'm not sure I
could still have a little kid because I
felt something with a kid the kid didn't
matter to me you know I mean so the kid
is one thing I can't be like guy though
Jimmy we can't chill together no more
because your mama's I didn't do what you
think is very pragmatic but just like
seeing the child and just constantly
being reminded of
fidelia's results will probably be very
tough there's a whole bunch of men who
are expected to still stay in that
child's life of course is it even more
crazy that the state makes you culpable
for that child financially that's crazy
that you are are financially liable for
a child that is proven not to be yours
especially when the court system is all
about proof and then you got proof that
it's not your and then you still got
yeah I agree
here's the flip side of that though with
the flip side is that the way the state
sees it is that there's a child that
needs to be taken care
I understand that but if the mother that
has to take care of that you see the
thing that happen is that men don't have
they don't have a lot to say about the
future of their opportunity you know
they don't they don't have a lot of we
can't force the abortion and we can't
force you to keep the job the women
always have the final say they got the
final say all right
so in that case if it's not mine you
can't force me no more so basically
you're saying it's her body her choice
your money my money your body your
choice my money my money what's up guys
with you yelling protects the grill and
you and you're not sure what's going on
I always tell people plan B should be
plan a plan B should just be the plan
clintus do you want a glass of water no
whoa girl you won't drink that glass of
water and take that with you that's
always bothered me it's like whenever
you bring up that point that you made
earlier we can always say well you know
what you had your choice when you stuck
it inside her and I'm always like but it
goes both ways
no it goes back to women not being
liable they're not liable with that if I
put my inside you if you didn't do that
you didn't want it it's all my choice
it's on me the same way we say that a
woman don't have they don't have a
choice what he cannot oh if he had
explained her boss it's not hurt I
wanted it is him that lured her into the
same thing it's all me it's not her it's
me yes my fault it's my fault it's my
choice it was me me me me me me me my
brother his lunch so that's what it is
yeah I just think it's a thing that men
have just at one point where they get to
make a choice where it's the inception
whereas woman can change her mind at any
point and obviously she has more
responsibility cuz she carries the child
so I understand but it just interests me
that like there's
no understanding from ladies when it
comes to this no absolutely not
and they don't want you know you don't
water engage in that you don't want to
have this discussion they don't like
okay yeah you want to be heard but she's
choosing not to hear someone no that's
not debatable that's not debatable we
can't talk about this it's like what we
can't talk about no there is no
discussion to be had and I remember
reading some of those comments on the
last video that we did about child
support I'm Anna more tragedy here's the
story I've experienced this firsthand as
a military veteran while I was active my
first child was unlawfully taken from me
after I began the divorce process I've
got my lawyer and went to court
immediately she made all claims of
domestic and emotional all were debunked
immediately I as a man was an abused
husband she threatened to go to my
command and make false claims if I
fought against it not because I'm scared
about a new I couldn't put hands on her
no matter what going to work with black
guys busted lips making up stories after
story I fought through all of that if I
was able to leave her continue to be a
great dad but she was narcissistic and
egotistical because I broke free from
her she did not she did the only thing
she could continue to me through my
child she moved back to her home in
Chicago I lost custody and was ordered
to pay child support of eight hundred
and ninety seven dollars plus decreasing
spousal support of one thousand and
ninety seven dollars for a year my
ex-wife continually refused to follow
court-ordered visitation and flat-out
denied my visitation several times even
though I was agreed I went back to court
and was denied changes every time I
spent money too I spent deployment money
to visit my child all to see her
sparingly I had to watch my daughter
grow up through email social media
long story short even after getting
multiple times by the California Family
course I never gave up came close to a
few times because it felt hopeless but I
held strong going to court every year
for nine years and I did it I finally
got full custody of her my daughter will
be 14 this year we've bonded strong and
all I have to do is continue life
support if anybody's going through the
same struggle don't give up your child
needs to you know what's weird is when
the mother is really like dysfunctional
and like got all kinds of problems but
she's still awarded custody yeah like
you got to prove that that lady is bad
before you get anything yet from the
family courts yeah yeah and it's crazy
because even if you
that child's not yours and you're forced
to pay child support and stuff like that
even by the time you prove it and you
get through all the whole process the
courts will not pay you back you'll not
get any of that money that they lost the
day you paid yeah so now that you're
paying for lawyers to get it to stop but
all that money that you lost you're not
gonna get it back so imagine if somebody
was unlawfully stealing from you you
proved it in court
won the case and you still didn't get
your money back the person is not gonna
be reprimanded for that no tell them go
so they're not gonna get represent it's
like you stole unlawfully from that
person now as it's been proven that you
stole in any cases you're either
supposed to return the goods or pay or
be I don't know there's a pin not a
penalty just something there has to be
somebody if nothing there's nothing
natto natto so it's crazy I pay child
support for a child that wasn't mine for
about five years the garnish might check
over it I called and talked to people in
the division many times who said it was
settled but it never was ended up going
to court with the woman with a child
there where she said she never met me
before before a judge finally ended it
it was all that mix up somehow with
names and you can see mines is common
but that that that was it but that was
it no SS number no birth date just name
and the other guy was from a different
state and just so you know I was not
able to recover any of the money I was
forced to pay of course on a technical
error yeah that wouldn't fury me so much
because I paid taxes and I already felt
like I'm feeling stolen from if I had to
pay child support for a kid who wasn't
mine and the admit it was wrong and I
cannot get my mom joining Isis all those
things that is crazy I'm not taking care
of a kid that's not mine and I'm not
paying for but I understand it from
someone else chooses to my thing is just
if they choose not to
they shouldn't be financially liable
that's my personal opinion maybe you
disagree anyways that's it for today
leave your comments below
[Music]
I decided to post a Mima troll the
lady's a little bitter because you know
this guy like you stays home and do not
mean you stays home Anja's edit I go out
I'm meeting after 10 I have people that
out of me now I'm gonna be walking down
the CP Bubba what you mean like a real
woman something when you're two people
on one account you don't get a
notification when someone posts
something understand you only get the
notification so this dude gonna pose as
trash sleep on I start to get bored pie
oh hell no oh yeah of course please
explain the rationale behind this and I
started getting like what the hell is
this
like what did he knew and sometimes you
know if that wasn't preached but
sometimes it's really just a blur it's
Apple going on a tangent and being like
yeah let me peel reduce aching let me
trouble she was gonna happen
hey let me do an experiment let me test
the waters let me go all social
experiment on you and then I just see my
box going on and buzz going on and I'm
like what what did he do people were mad
so are you saying that a woman should
write it I even when she disrespected
like this no I'm not mad yes you could
some good comments in here are you
serious and I was like you're not a real
woman if you disagree you're a fake
woman with fire-crotch I was obviously
trolling know well people don't know
because you write it down you know the
parallel is broke what parallel well the
parallel would like how they talked
about two men and they're like if you
don't do this you're not a real man I'd
I would get that but it doesn't mean
that the people that you're gonna get or
the one perpetrators of that so they're
not gonna get that it's not because you
want to see like hey you know what
you're saying oh well you're not a real
woman for that and the person you said
that to actually said that to a man no
if not because they are it's not that my
ideas not that they're saying it I'm not
saying it matter what you hold up hold
up my idea is not that they're the ones
saying that's not what I'm trying to say
okay what I'm trying to say is that's a
common thing that's said often in the
general general you understand right
it's like if I made a joke about men
need to get back in the kitchen most
people understand
in that that's a play on the fact that
we tell women again forget that it's
just the purpose of the thing you put
that there with our contents back you
put that there and after that when the
person replies you go back on it and you
double down and it's just interesting
how susceptible people are to anything
like that it's like it's like people
will send me articles and look can you
believe that they want to throw black
man inside of a chicken coop and make
them pick Khan and I'm like it's written
by the onion calm down or the beaverton
like did you not even look at the
headline and see where it's the most
adverse emotion first and so people are
so susceptible to little things things
that are very obviously jokes or they'll
see a meme and it'll be like it'll be
Barack Obama's face and it'll say stuff
like peace can only be achieved through
inner peace Barack Obama I like just cuz
there's a quote and a picture doesn't
mean he actually sent it but people are
so susceptible to ever quote from
Marilyn Monroe they're like I saw that
like the other day it was a picture of
her and it says I never said that if you
can't handle me at my earth you cannot
have me and my aunt Marilyn much never
said that all right cool okay okay she
never said that so justify if it was
just a picture of Marilyn Monroe in the
back hold it up if you want to hold it
up hold up
yeah okay is there's no problem with
that yeah hold it do your thing Elaine
but don't justify with something that
someone didn't say no and stop telling
people what real men should do and what
real women should do okay gotta live
your lives be me yourselves enjoy I know
I was just laughing the whole time when
people was getting man in the comments I
know that's it for today leave your
comments below